hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're gonna be unboxing the new
GoPro Hero 6 now this just came out so
I'm excited to take a look at it I've
had so many GoPros I'm a huge GoPro fan
one thing that I'm not a fan of by GoPro
is the
oh my god
[Music]
but let's not get into that we're here
to talk about the euro-6 one of the
biggest upgrade features that you can
now do 240 frames a second in 1080p the
4k 60 and the 240 1080p is kind of
interesting because now you can also do
that on the new iPhone so I look forward
to testing those out and seeing which
one looks better it's waterproof up to
33 feet voice activated and it has the
touch LCD on the back let's do this oh
this is I don't even need my knife it's
a nice little tap here just all ready
for me to do this looks very very
similar to the Hero 5 very similar I
mean I'm pretty sure it's almost exactly
the same
[Music]
one of the things that I was most upset
about when I did my previous unboxing
which I watched back because I was like
what do I do last year when I had box
this the first thing that I'll notice is
my hair was much more blond my camera
was tilted my lighting wasn't as good my
biggest complaint though was that the
new GoPro was USBC power oh come on now
not mostly I was upset because all of
the other things that I had with
microUSB or of course lightning but now
at this point it's only been a year and
now I want everything to be USB c-e-o
while the times change my friends so
we've got a USBC cable we've got our two
sticky mounts and our battery and our
GoPro so here's all our stuff now they
said no a huge GoPro fan what I love
most about GoPro is its versatility you
can take it anywhere you can throw it in
your purse if it gets wet does it matter
we're losing light
you might be confused as to what's going
on you might like just you know you're
crazy and you're right I potentially
could be but this is the GoPro Hero 5
and this is the hero 6 let's take a look
at them side-by-side this is the 6 this
is the 5 looking at them head-on
they basically look exactly the same
they did change a little icon here on
the 6 it looks more like a power button
as opposed to the little capture button
that will allow you to like add moments
let's set this up so we can hopefully
get outside here very very quickly ok
we're gonna charge it and do a setup at
the same time here's our little welcome
screen hello how are you got my GoPro
all paired up to my phone which is great
because you're able to control it
through your phone you can adjust
settings and it's much easier than using
the interface on the GoPro my bad
recently at 13% oh boy I guess let's
take it outside and test it out real
quick
little test holding up both gopro
side-by-side and comparing the quality
of each one we're shooting 4k 30 frames
a second and in wide view so these are
basically side-by-side each should be
fairly the same quality our GoPros are
now filming each other I can't wait to
take these out in some bright light I'm
gonna do a full GoPro only vlog so ready
see what that looks like to see is this
something that you could just vlog with
look at my setup back here stuff phone
tripods battery shoes so we're currently
here editing having a lovely time
there's a problem because when you're
shooting in the higher framerate and now
encodes a different codec so it's now
using HEV C which is great but I haven't
upgraded my mac to high sierra yet just
regular basic sierra does not support it
so i'm not able to edit in final cut or
even open any of the files so right now
i'm having to convert it all
hopefully the footage looks okay i don't
know this isn't this was unexpected I
didn't realize this is gonna happen 240
frames a second on the GoPro
Slovo 240 frames a second on the iPhone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching you
hope you guys enjoyed this quick little
unboxing tomorrow I plan on taking the
GoPro Hero 6 out and I'm gonna do a
little vlog test basically just gonna do
an entire vlog all day on the hero 6 and
see what it looks like I'll probably
post that video in maybe a few days from
now so stay tuned if you're not
subscribed make sure you guys click the
subscribe button and be sure to turn on
alerts because I'm not really sure if
subscriptions work the way that they're
supposed to on YouTube but the alerts
you get a notification so you guys will
know when I post a new video anyway I'll
see you guys soon look for more fun
videos hopefully coming up soon I've got
a ton of cooking videos coming up all
themed around Halloween and yeah I know
what you're saying cuz I read the
comments I'm really confused Justine
what type of channel is this is it a
tech channel is it a vlogging channel is
it a Cooking Channel who are you what is
this place I wish I have an answer for
you I would say that my channel is
basically an extension of myself it is
all of the things that I like and
hopefully you can find something that
you guys like you're - I'm gonna go edit
now
[Music]